اخيرا كتاب سيره الامير هاري على رفوف
المكتبات والمتاجر صار في متناول محبي
الامير وكاريه على السواء لتصفح الصفحات
ال 416 وما تحتويه من فيض من التفاصيل
المثيره عن حياته وعن الخلافه داخل عائلته
من كشفه عن مشاجره مع اخيه وصولا الى
اعترافه بقتل 25 مقاتلا في طالبان وكلامه
عن طاعه المخدرات كلها امور اثارت ردود
فعل عديده وستترك بلا شك اثرا على مبيعات
الكتاب وشعبيه الامير
اشتريت الكتاب لانني اريد ان اكون جزءا من
التاريخ ولمعرفتي ما جرى في القصر خصوصا
الامور التي لم نسمع عنها من قبل وكيف
تصرفت الصحافه مع هاري
لترويج كتابه وما زعم مثيره طالت افراد
العائله الملكيه صدمت متابع الامير
وعائلته من جهه ومؤيد العائله المالكه من
جهه اخرى وان كانت الغالبيه ترى ضروره
ابقاء اسرار العائله الملكيه ومشاكل
اعضائها حديثه القصر لن اقتني الكتاب
لاننا قضينا وقتا كافيا للحديث عن هذا
الموضوع وحصل على ما يكفي من الدعايه ولا
اظن ان من المنطقي شراء الكتاب
اتعاطف مع الامير لكن معه انه يستحق اضاعه
وقتي لقراءته
سجن الامير هاري الملايين من الجنيهات من
مبيعات الكتاب وسيخص جزء منها لمنظمه
خيريه اسسها لمساعده الاطفال المصابين
بفيروس نقص المناعه في افريقيا
يحتل كتابه مذكرات الامير هاري المرتبه
الاولى في قوائم مبيعات الكتب على موقع
امازون ويتوقعوا ان يحضر الكتاب باقبال
كبير في المكتبات بعد حمله التسويقيه منذ
الاعلامي عن نشر سيرته الذاتيه
كعادتها التزمت العائله الملكيه السمطه
ولم تعلق على مزاعم الكتاب تركه الكلام
الهاري اللي يحكموا على تداعيات اصداره
على المدى الطويل مصطفى زاروه العربيه
لندن